so you want to get shred in 2024 well
you're going to need lots of exag
testosterone and to pick better parents
but if you're not going to do either of
those things I've got 12 protein packed
recipes that require zero Time Zero prep
have almost zero carbs almost zero fat
and tons and tons of protein this loan
has over 200 g of protein and almost
none of the other macros and I'm going
to show you this recipe at the end of
the video first let's talk about
breakfast Chef bro Rd to the rescue so
breakfast the least talked about thing
of the day was like breakfast champions
for old people uh it's also great for
gains so uh if you're somebody who
struggles to eat enough like I do or if
you're somebody who eats too much also
works for you I'm going to show you how
to make a 100 G protein bomb for zero
prep in just a minute using stuff that
you have at home that actually tastes
delicious so number one I use this F
yogurt there's plenty of other brands it
doesn't really matter I use this 0% this
puppy has 94 g of protein in it and just
under 500 calories for this whole thing
and if you have this this whole thing it
is spilling and for people who struggle
with dairy yogurt tends to do a little
bit better than somebody who just drinks
pure milk cuz it's already turned so
already has some of those metabolites
and all that fancy stuff that I know
nothing about that being said I do know
that if you eat that compared to
drinking gallon of milk that's easier on
the stomach now we're going to take
something that's all natural and we're
going to ruin it with lots of artificial
flavors so that it's actually delicious
and you can use a bowl what I usually do
is I just put it in here because I don't
like dishes and I will take fruit punch
I like Berry personally uh there's
different ones there's like a berry
sangria that's pretty good and the nice
thing with this is that these are always
available everywhere so if you travel
and you usually have your Main Stays at
home you're like shoot what do I do like
almost every grocery store nowadays has
has Greek yogurt and so I put about half
of one of these guys in and this is like
for a pitcher so I figur this is about
half a pitcher of fluid so I put half of
one of these guys in and then I mixy
mixy mixy now if you do need a bigger
bowl cuz it does make it easier to mix
just for visuals I'll show you guys you
put this guy
in that looks great and then we just mix
this guy so this is my prep time can we
start the timer here's my prep
time you also get a nice little forearm
pump so you get a little pre-workout
workout if you know what I'm talking
about what's cool about this is it
actually smells like Yokai or Danon or
any of your favorite uh you know yogurt
yogurt brands that we know and loved
when we grew up and then later found out
they were made by big farmer to kill us
and all that stuff anyways I like Fruity
Pebbles so this is my preferred uh
cereal of choice let's take this guy out
and so here's the cool part is that this
can stretch a really long way so a cup
of this has 140 calories in it and 30 G
of carbs pretty much nothing else it's
almost all carbs all right so let me
show you guys a fancy trick so leave the
actual cereal scooper as one cup in
there so that you always know what
you're getting every time and and so for
me I pull out my cup make sure it's even
on the top don't give yourself a heaping
scoop all right and then after that I
know I've got 140 calories of carbs and
so rather than mix them in because then
they get soggy what I'll do is I'll
sprinkle some on top doesn't that look
delicious and then I'll peel off the
first layer they stay crunchy and then
I'll put the next layer
on and then I'll peel off the second
layer so I can have this nice Fruity
Pebble crunch all the way through and
you can see I didn't like I barely used
a lot of my cup and I just did two kind
of coverings worth and you can use like
a cup is plenty you could do a half cup
like if you're dieting cuz I've done
this when I was dieting if you use a/2
cup of this it's 70 calories it's 15 G
of carbs and this thing's 500 calories
of protein with basically nothing else
and it almost nothing else right and so
that's my choice it's like this is a
filling breakfast all right you put all
this in
here that is a filling filling breakfast
it looks like a massive bowl of cereal
except this has almost 100 g of protein
in it it doesn't take any time to prep
and if you eat it out of there which is
what I normally do you don't even have
any dishes let's see if it's as good as
I remember
it still delicious by the way if you do
have a beard beard Nemesis so definitely
check yourself in the mirror before you
leave the house other you have pink
all over your face that being said let's
go to the next one by the way I'm making
these recipes because the last video I
did so many of you guys commented saying
like give us a part two and so this is
part two and we'll have the recipes in
the link in the description enjoy so
this was a lunch that I had for like a
couple years because I tend to stick
with the same thing for a really long
time until one day I decide I'm going to
have something different but this is an
awesome lunch so this is Ezekiel bread
which is just fancy organic schmancy
bread that has I don't know less
preservatives whatever it's in the
refrigerated section it's like a dollar
and a half more anyways so I had this
stuff cuz I figured if I'm going to have
it every day I try to eat better stuff
so that being said take two of these
guys and if you want to know per slice
each slice of this thing is only 80
calories which is not bad for a slice of
bread especially given how like weighty
it is so some some slices of bread are
like kind of foamy you could like mash
it in your hand and put into a little
itty bitty ball this has more weight to
it so it's 80 calories it's got 5 gr of
protein in it 15 G of carbs and almost
no fat now if you like toast which I do
there's speed toasters that can toast it
in like half the time or a third of the
time and every minute is precious to me
so I have a speed toaster that I toast
these guys in but just to keep this
video rolling imagine these are toasted
all right so once it's toasted what I do
and I've experimented with different
ways to eat this cuz I ate it every
single day for like 2 years is I have
fat-free cream cheese all right so this
is zero fat cream cheese which you're
like how does that even work honestly no
idea it's probably some sort of Franken
food it just kind of has the texture of
cream cheese I think they use milk to
make it who honestly knows I don't
really care that much but it tastes
pretty good the way to to do this guy is
uh usually sometimes they'll have like
little measurement things on here um if
you have a scale because you want to be
precise awesome I have done it enough
times to know kind of like what a
tablespoon looks like um and so that's
about what that looks like and by the
way these are lowfat locks again I'm a
lowfat guy which means it's pretty if
you have fish that doesn't have carbs in
it and used to have fat what's left
protein so this is pretty much close to
the same macros as a chicken breast kind
of cool um it is a little bit drier just
to be fair but for me I didn't really
care that much The Taste was good enough
for me and that worked different ways
you can eat it version one is you put
the cream cheese on and you layer that
on top I don't like that because the
bread starts to get soggy the next way
you can do it is that you can put the
salmon on here and then bite by bite put
the cream cheese on that way does work
cuz it doesn't like the salmon doesn't
really make the bread wet but the
problem is that the Salmon's really hard
to bite into cuz then you pull the whole
thing off of the bread and so after
eating this a lot of times I have some
settled on the third way of doing it
which is that I actually Mash this guy
up into like salmon
tartar all right so I just cut the
out of this thing and I really I'm not
even trying to like grind it up I just
want to make it in big enough slices
that if it comes like I'm not going to
tear the whole thing off the bread when
I eat
it so that I like I still have salmon
that's on there when I'm eating it all
right tricks of the trade now once I
have this now what I'll do is I'll take
my cream cheese I'll throw this guy on
I'll some with this on and then I just
take my bite and I just do that over and
over and over again and that has been
how I ate it for years and years and
years so the bread stays crunchy I don't
have to accidentally eat half my salmon
in one bite and then just eat plain ass
bread the rest of the time and the cream
cheese stays cold because if the cream
cheese is cold and then the bread is hot
they just end up being lukewarm and
sucking and so this stays crunchy and
hot this stays cold and creamy and then
I have a bitable amount of s and it
doesn't tear off at once and that is how
I eat this thing now let's talk about
macros real quick so remember this
thing's all protein this is more or less
all protein and this is low calorie so
if you didn't want to eat Ezekiel I
would just say go with low calorie bread
I just try to minimize my carb intake
unless I'm trying to eat them on purpose
and so I pretty much just eat protein
throughout the day and then when I am
going to eat carbs never skip dessert I
go any e carbs for real and I eat as
many carbs as I feel like so like I said
in the beginning I try to eat around 100
g of protein per meal and so I would
actually do three of these guys and I
eat them as open face sandwiches so I
have fewer carbs overall and so I'd put
about 4 oz of this protein locks on here
I'd have my bread and I'd have two three
maybe five grams of protein that would
come from the cream cheese and so
between the 20-ish that comes from this
the 3 to four that comes from this and
the five that comes from this I get
about 30ish grams of protein per Open
Face Sandwich there's my 90 if you guys
are paying attention at home this is
actually not enough salmon for what
would be on one sandwich so the salmon
gets stacked up because remember this is
protein right so I'm going to show you
this because this is aesthetically what
it would look like at a fancy restaurant
but in the brasic kitchen this is how
much salmon would actually be on your
sandwich all right so I actually tried
to eat as much as I could on these open
face puppies so that I could then get
swo all right so there we go now I put
it like this and I could take these
massive man bites and have three of
these guys but I didn't want to throw
away pounds of salmon uh for no reason
cuz those salmon give their lives for
us like that boom
delicious so I have three of those guys
90 g of protein all in calories 240
calories come from the bread probably
100 or two from the cream cheese and the
rest is just protein coming from the
salmon and if you have a beard once
again so you don't look like you have a
facial wipe your
face delicious so we just crushed lunch
now let's talk about snacks on the go so
two of my favorite snacks that go on the
go that you can eat pretty much anywhere
in the continent in the United States
are you got jerky and you got light key
Point string cheese all right so let's
dive in so you might not know and again
this isn't for all the healthy people if
you're going to be a healthy person then
just go watch another video but if you
just want protein this is for you all
right now original jerky and I found
this out lat here has a lot of protein
in it all right so this is this little
guy has six servings of 10 g of protein
there's 60 g of protein in this there's
less than 500 calories not bad right so
it's 480 calories 60 g of protein and so
not a bad uh snack that you're on the
way on the go so if you don't have time
to eat or something like that but you
are a bigger guy and you need more
calories and if you're a smaller guy and
need fewer calories just cut it in half
all right now the other thing is string
cheese now I use scoops of weight
protein or pure protein sources as a
good lipus test t for is this a pure or
less pure protein Source all right so
like if you have a like the purest
version of this is that you have a 120
calorie scoop of protein it has 24 grish
of protein that's about as lean as
you're going to get in any kind of
normal food now if you have four of
these guys it's 200 calories and 24 g of
protein all right so not I mean really
really close and the added amount that
comes from this is fat so there's 2 and
half Gams of fat there's almost no carbs
in this um in the string cheese and so
if I have four string cheeses and this
guy I've got 84 g of protein and you're
like man four string cheeses and all
that it's like yeah it's kind of like a
meal which is kind of the point and so
you can have this on the Go and all in
all you'd be up 680 calories with 84 g
of protein and the stuff keeps great so
if you just want to like have a snack on
the go and you don't eat 100 grams in
one sitting you just open it up take a
bite tough not all of them are
good but that one's okay I'll bet you
the string cheese goes down a little e
easier cuz that's super dry and you
canare this with a lovely Savon water
and this guy though people were like how
do you eat six strink cheese you got to
like bite one bite two it you eat six of
them honestly six string cheeses it's
just cuz they serve these to like
four-year-olds so like the string cheese
is just not that much cheese it's like
two bites so it's really just having 12
bites of cheese it's not nearly as much
as you think about they just package it
like so they can charge you more there's
not that much it's this it's not a lot
of cheese all
right see there you go it's like three
bites I'm remembering now while I eat
this jerky and the cheese actually taste
delicious together it's meat and cheese
it's actually really good so this is for
those of you who are just rich and feel
like spending more money but still don't
want to have anything but protein bring
on the next one so I used to eat this
when I was cutting so this is my cutting
diet
so this is shrimp that's been peeled and
cooked already so you can get this from
the freezer section or if you're really
fancy you can get from the Fresh section
I prefer the freezer section because
it's cheaper so for all you fancy
boom shrimp which all you
have to do is defrost it this came pre
all what ever all right so you just let
it thaw all right the way that I did is
I just do it under the sink cuz it thaws
it faster and then it just comes coldish
and then you take this
puppy this is to cocktail sauce which by
the way has 30 calories per4 cup which
you're not going to have more than like
A4 a cup anyways all right maybe two all
right so this is probably I don't know
a/ cup maybe and so I got 60 calories of
tartar sauce so all you got to do is dip
one of these puppies in this is the
fancy eating instruction herle B that's
it very easy you can do whatever you
want and the nice thing is that most
people can unless you're allergic to
shrimp most people digest shrimp pretty
well and so the nice thing is that
usually shrimp has a lot of volume and
so it's very filling at least I found it
filling and so if you want to be fancy
you can do that and if you want to be a
little less fancy you can have like 8 O
of chicken and 8 O of shrimp or if you
want to be a little bit less fancy but
still feel fancy you can have 4 oz of
shrimp and 12 ounces of other
doesn't really matter it's all just
protein but the cool thing about shrimp
specifically is that shrimp has zero
carbs and zero fat the thing is pure
protein and so unless you add fat to it
or you add carbs to it there ain't going
to be any all right and so the only
thing in this meal that has anything
besides protein is just the cocktail
sauce and this thing like a little bit
goes a long way and I barely even count
this stff when I was eating it so now
that we finished our fancy fancy shrimp
shrimp dinner dinner now let's talk
about beef and cauliflower all right so
this one is one that is a classic also
one that I ate a lot when I was dieting
because I needed to really get my uh my
protein up and my uh my calories down
but all I do is I have the leanest
ground beef that I can find so this is
937 usually you can find 964 if you find
a good place that does it just get that
um you can also do it with ground turkey
um it doesn't matter uh if you were
really poor uh I used to just buy
chicken breasts and then put them
through a food processor which I had for
my dog at the time and so I just feed
them in and just grinds it up for you
and I just have all this ground chicken
breast and that worked pretty good for
me so one is you've got your beef or
your meat that's going to be lean two is
you've got these microwavable packets of
riced cauliflower all right now this
stuff is heavy like it's very filling
and the nice thing with this is that if
you've ever had an uncle Benz or a quick
or minute rice or whatever it works the
exact same way all right so you just
crack the top put it in the microwave
and heat it up now one thing I will say
is that the beef you usually prep at one
point during the week so you're going to
have a few pounds of ground beef already
hopefully somewhere in your home and
then all you do is you just got to add
something to it so that it makes it into
a meal and that's why this is a no prep
deal now up to this point you're like
okay so you're just talking beef and
cauliflower like why is this a meal good
point because that on its own would be
disgusting and so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to show you how I make a
sauce that is both delicious and not
nutritious in terms of it's uh not chalk
packed with macronutrients but it's
actually just chocked full of
deliciousness and not a lot of cows all
right so let's put these puppies
together and I'll show you the secret
sauce and we'll enjoy it together so
first things first we're going to start
with the meat look at that cooked it
already man we're Speedy who said this
was Zero prep anyways so next thing is
we got to take our cauliflower and we're
going to Nuke this thing
right so now we've got these two puppies
so how we're going to make this
delicious cuz right now this looks like
dog food and I agree with you so we're
going to enter secret ingredient number
three the sauce so let's talk calories
about mayonnaise all right so one first
thing is that we actually accidentally
bought the wrong one this should be
light mayo most light mayos are about 35
calories per tablespoon this is this
puppy now if you want to not keep
measuring spoon by spoon by spoon
which you can have lots of error you
just put the thing on a food scale and
just see how many grams it is it's a
much easier way to do that but for the
visual demonstration purpos of this
video let's rock with it so if I've got
100 call it 30 calories that I want to
eat all right in terms of fat I've got
one of these
guys and the reason that the the the
weighing it is kind of useful is cuz you
always have some kind of like leftover
on the spoon and so you're kind of
counting the same thing twice and so I
like just weighing it but it is what it
is all right here we go now if you also
want a little hack uh use the spoon that
you did the scooping with to do the
mixing because that way you get to use
some of the stuff that's on there that
you had to get credit for in your
calories all right so that's 130ish
calories cuz each one was 35 * 4
whatever 140 there you go 140 calories
all right fantastic next one is Hermos
secret Special Sauce which is just
Sriracha all right so then this guy I've
actually I just don't count calories on
hot sauce cuz there's not enough to
really give a and so I put a little
bit in depending on your desired hotness
levels now I like a little spice to my
to my stuff all right and we go a little
mixy mixy oo you can even smell it woo
that smells like heartburn yes it does
you're going to feel that tomorrow yes
you will okay fantastic now I take
sweetness and add this in so this is
Stevia if you want to use Splenda that
works too all right now again this is
like spicy and sweet are to flavor all
right I like to add a couple in you'll
get a feel for it add one in see if you
like it and then add another if you're
like oh I like this to be sweet cuz what
ends up happening is when you put this
whole thing
together this becomes this really nice
fatty sweet spicy mayo all right look at
that it's kind of fancy right all right
so check this out so we combine our
forces together boom we've got our our
rice and our beef and then we go mixy
mixy again I'm going to give you another
hack if you need to get sauce and you
want to stretch it further instead of
just like taking this and just dumping
it in what you
do take a little bit of this dip your
spoon go on top and then take a bite
that's it actually is really good so
that being said that's how it works all
right and I do it that way because you
can you can you'd be amazed at how many
more calories you can get if you just
dip your fork or dip your spoon before
you do it and if you're really clever
about it I try to put the sauce on the
bottom side of the utensil so that it's
like directly on my tongue so it feels
like there's way more sauce but there
really isn't and so that's you can
stretch 140 calories for a pound of meat
so now that we just did a little spicy
spicy let's do something sweet I'm going
to show you the nastiest ghetto fabulous
way to get protein you've possibly ever
seen and it's so weird you're probably
going to try it all right this is 100 g
of protein in one serving with zero
preparation of any kind this is the only
food on the market that I'm aware of
that you can literally take off the
shelf get 100 gram of pure protein with
no fat or carbs and it is egg whites now
you're like well how are you g to zero
prep egg whites well something you might
not know is that egg whites are ultra
pasteurized they're not even pasteurized
they're Ultra pasturized which is why if
you look at expiration dates on eggs
they're like super far in the future
because there's almost no bacteria in it
all right now you might be like okay
what is he going to do with the bowl
great question actually we have this
here so you can see it all right but
this is how you do it and you're like
wait Hershey syrup zero sugar yeah now
you're getting where I'm going with this
now if you grew up having chocolate milk
as a kid which I didn't cuz my dad
didn't want me to be fat but uh if you
did good for you um I did get them at
school though they had the little cards
of milk you know those CR yeah I had
some and that was like one of my big
sources of protein ground anyways so
what you do is step one take ultra
pasteurized egg whites I call these tall
boys all right there are 20 servings of
5 g of protein in this puppy that is 100
g of protein there are exactly 0 g of
fat and exactly z g of carbs in this
entire thing it is pure protein and then
we take pure delicious where there's
exactly zero g of
protein and 0o G of fat in this and
probably just gelatin and who
knows what Frankenstein's piss anyways
and so you take this all right and
there's 32 servings in here and so a
tablespoon if you remember what the Mayo
looked like it doesn't matter because
there's not that many calories in this
anyways it's five calories per
tablespoon all right so we're going to
put some of this in
here all right that's probably like 3
tablespoons 4 tablespoons all right and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go mixy mixy either the way keep your
finger on the top hear that mixy mixy
you can almost hear the gains
loading and
you and that's it let's see
this it's just like chocolate egg whites
that's all it is and if you want to add
more in you can but I will say after
having drank many many many of these Pro
tip drink 95% the last five is like kind
of gritty so I would just like take 95 g
of protein called a w um and the thing
is is like if you had this entire thing
for everyone at home who like wait how
much did he put in there this whole
thing is 150 calories you're not going
to use the whole thing if you used a
third of it it'd be 50 calories which I
didn't even use a 20th of this
all right so like it's going to be okay
but you can make this thing as chocolate
as you
want so that would be an ex extremely
chocolatey massive
nonsense look at the texture here look
how thick that is kind of delicious
right look at that it's like real
chocolatey this is uh a great way to
start the day so you can knock out half
of your protein in a single sitting
doing this if you need 200 g of protein
and if you just eat like a normal person
the other three meals of your day you'll
probably get 200 g while we're on the
Chocolate Train let's keep it going all
right so let's uh let's dive in so one
of the things I didn't know is that
Premier Protein actually make cereal
there's some other cereals that claim to
be protein cereals but let's be real
they're not really protein cereals they
just like a bunch of soy crisps put
together that still have shitloads of
carbs and fat but this one's actually
pretty good so this is one cup of this
guy is 180 calories and 20 g of protein
which is basically the equivalent of a
good it's like a little bit more than
literally pure protein in a scoop and a
little bit less than most protein bars
so like really pure version of protein
and so if we put a cup of this
in but let's be real no one eats one cup
of cereal all right so what we're going
to do is actually have a protein
breakfast of champions and have one cup
wait for it two cups three cups all
right so there we go you got three cups
of this puppy this is 60 g of protein
and then open up one of these
guys make sure it's good oh yeah well
this is from the uh this is a I think
this is March of 23d three oo it's a
great vintage anyways so we dump this
puppy in
there which I'm really doing for visual
effect cuz what I would actually do is
actually pour this in the bowl first and
then put one scoop at a time in so I
could keep the cereal crunchy but it's a
little bit more dramatic this way for
the visual cams all right and so we're
talk about zero prep
protein 90 g of protein like almost the
purest amount of calorie per calorie
protein out there um this is all way
though so to be fair if you were
somebody who doesn't do dairy well this
would not be for you um but if you do
handle Dairy well which I do um this is
just this is a good
time so this is 700 calories 90 g of
protein and probably cheap as so if
you're broke and you want some protein
that takes zero time to cook and is
delicious I throw this puppy on the list
especially if you like chocolate you can
handle milk enjoy if you're riding this
br rasic Voyage with me then you will
love this one too so this is a lunch
meal or a dinner meal if you're kind of
wild you can even have a breakfast cuz
you're just a psychopath that
being said all we do is we take this
chicken of the sea can tuna which I
think is my favorite flavor of tuna just
cuz I like saying Chicken of the Sea
make sure that you have it in water
rather than oil so that there's not
extra cows in it you can open this guy
with one hand not really everyone uses
two hands to do a can opener ask the
disabled is that too soon anyways uh
that being said this guy has 66 g of
protein and only 300
calories ice cold all right so this
thing has zero carbs basically zero fat
and only protein so one of the nice
things with most Seafoods uh especially
Crustaceans this is not Crustaceans but
but in general tuna is a very very lean
uh protein and so that's why it's lean
all right so that's 66 g of protein 300
calories that's step one in this puppy
step two is we're going to take this F
or Fage depending on how you want to say
it all right take a 3/4 cup get this guy
in here
here by the way whoever invented these
ones that have these little rims well
done don't have affiliate links don't
know what brand it is but if you find
those then awesome on you all right
we're going to put this thing here I
actually already did this but this is a
second take so deal with it all right
that being said this is now in total 300
calories of tuna and 90 calories of
yogurt so 390 calories but here's the
cool part there's 86 G 84 g of protein
in this bowl and less than 400 calories
so let's this up with even less
calories all right next one is yellow
mustard guess how many calories are in
this L zero and this one because it's
zero Cals you can add add libidum which
is Latin for as much as you want
all right so now what we do is we go
mixy mixy you'll notice mixy mix is a
common step in our no prep our no prep
fantasies all right mixy
mixy also if you like pepper pepper ises
kind of good in here and uh some people
like celery but like again I don't care
about prepping that much I want to do
like as little as possible to make
something good but if you like some
texture celery and cucumbers uh salt and
pepper that kind of stuff works I I
usually just don't cuz I don't care
enough uh pepper I do usually have at
the table I don't usually prep with that
I just kind of sprinkle it on top all
right so now we've just got this
delicious yellow looking mustard bowl
and remember we only have 390 calories
still so like this is a meal like this
is like this is 84 g of protein less
than 4 00 calories if you had three of
these every day you'd probably be pretty
full you'd also be lean as because
it'd be less than 1,200 calories a day
all right so we take this set spoon put
it on set
bread a bite set easy peasy and if you
have a beard yet again check yourself
before you leave the house all right you
Psychopaths we're going from lunch to
breakfast again because you can't go in
order here we are all right so what
we're going to do is uh we're going to
take this egg whites that has all the
Hershey milk stuff in it um well I
forgot to buy two of these for this
video so so there's only going to be one
milk but we're going to pretend like
this is uh clear even though this is
going to look like dark chocolate eggs
but you know what it might be delicious
so we'll find out all right so we're
going to take our egg whites which are
nice and chocolatey all right and
remember this whole puppy has 100 g of
protein in it here's why this is cool is
that if you don't drink the eggs you can
just nuke them because you don't need a
pan to cook them so a lot of people
don't know this but uh you can just
microwave these guys and they just fluff
right up so usually they actually have
the directions on the thing and if they
don't they have it on the Google cool so
let's go microwave these puppies over
here I just Googled it and it said 90
seconds so we'll find out by the way
look at this fancy cookbook that we made
for you guys for free thank the team uh
they put that together for you guys so
hopefully you guys can just get more
jacked CU who doesn't want a more Jack
mation I mean I do all right so 90
seconds while the microwave is cooking
let me show you a little special edition
F I gave you guys the Fruity Pebbles and
Crystal Light fruit version there's also
a Cinnamon Toast Crunch version that I
have I think done pretty good with all
right so same original base of f but
here's the difference is that in the F
instead of squirting in Crystal Light
you're going to add in vanilla extract
mixy Mixie add in one or two packets of
your fake sugar of choice or real sugar
if you feel like adding calories I don't
care either way all right and then on
top of that instead of adding Fruity
Pebbles you go CTC like a king on top
sprinkle it and enjoy and if you want to
get fancy fancy and you're serving it
for your lady take some cinnamon do a
little dusting on top little chef's
kiss back to the microwave all right so
look at this looks like a
sule all right so we got our eggs all
sued which is French for Blow by the
way uh which is kind of funny all right
so we got our egg whites here and uh
obviously you know chocolate it's
probably delicious in and of itself
probably does take taste like a suai but
uh if you're less fancy than me which
maybe you are or maybe you're more fancy
than I am I just use canned canned
Salita all right and we just going to
pop this puppy all right and what I do
is I don't again I don't count calories
on Hots because I just don't care like
this whole thing is 150 calories for
this whole Mamba Jamba and I'm not going
to have anywhere close to you know
anything reasonable on this so I'm just
going to put some sauce on here
and like that's it now imagine this is
white instead of
chocolate but it's actually really good
it's really easy to do now here's the
thing is I made
like a cup maybe of eggs if this thing
was this whole tall boy i' need a bowl
like this like egg whites blow up in
terms of size and so if you are somebody
who's like on an extreme diet or
somebody has like a huge appetite and
you need to be full doing a tall boy of
this and actually cooking the eggs is a
mountain of food and so uh that's why I
drink them rather than eat them cuz I
don't even have the appetite to eat that
much even even when I'm like dieting and
starving I don't have the appetite to
eat that um but if you are somebody who
has that salsa plus egg whites plus
microwave zero prep zero skill all
protein all delicious all the time so
now that we're done with the salsa and
eggs let me tell you what I actually eat
for breakfast every day the world's
shortest and easiest 84 g of protein
that's 230 calories of Pop 460 in total
so 84 g of protein 460 calories all
delicious honestly Fair life you guys
did a gift to humanity by coming out
with this this is only recent by the way
until like not that long ago we just had
to eat chalk dust mixed with uh
and I was willing to do it hey willing
to do it for the gains um but these are
actually really good these just taste
like chocolate milk I prefer vanilla
obviously have chocolate I mean I'll
drink them both um they're both very
good but vanilla tastes like melted ice
cream it's really good and uh this is
how easy it is to prepare and make
this I think this is a summer month this
is probably bottled in
July just a hint you can taste some of
the floral undertones all right so last
but not least and the reason I'm doing
this one is because I actually up
one of the other 12 dishes so I couldn't
do it but this is actually what I have
for breakfast mday anyways all right so
that being said let's
do kudagra right cud if we want to get
fancy on it all right uh bro nachos so
there are three ingredients in Bron
nachos or Brin brot chips uh they are as
follows number one Quest cool ranch
chips side note this is the in my
opinion the best flavor they have bu a
long shot I mean the other ones are fine
but but like these borderline taste like
chips the other ones are like protein
chips um these are really really good so
number one got quest uh ranch chips
number two horel chili delicious make
sure that you get no beans cuz you want
beef in there uh what's cool about this
is uh there's lots of protein it lasts
forever you can buy them in bulk I'll
tell more about this stuff later number
three is Le or Fage depending on how you
feel like pronouncing it uh also more
protein you've noticed it's a common
theme and number four
salsa all right so let's rock and roll
let's go over the macros real quick so
number one this is 140 G sorry this is
140 calories 19 gram of protein I mean
this is leaner than most protein bars in
terms of calorie content and I think
they're delicious like this is this gets
close to just what a chicken breast is
so like really really pure source of
protein and also delicious um this
Hormel chili is uh is is 520 calories
per can 30 30 30 g of protein so a
little bit fattier but again we're
making a meal here and I'm trying to
make this bastic all right so there's
that so that's 520 calories this guy
we've already covered from earlier and
then salsa usually has no calories and
this is 5 calories per serving 50
calories for the whole thing so let's
assume that I want to have a bastic
voyage and we're going to go on it
together so number one is uh we're going
to try and eat a lot here all right so
let's make 100 g of protein per the usug
all right so we're going to go two two
bags of chips because why not all right
so that gets us 40 right off the bat now
obviously guys you can cut it in half
and if you're a little a little itty
bitty little itty bitty girl itty bitty
guy you can uh you can just have half
all right that's fine all right so we
got 40 g of protein so far all right now
we're going to take our horel chili so
what we're going to do here is we're
going
to this guy here there we go all right
and then we're going to put a little
chili on
there little spoony spoon oh yeah oh
yeah oh
yeah there we
go all right so now we got 70 GS of
protein and we
need 30 more and obviously if you want
to like have more protein you could just
have a leaner meat this is just fun and
easy because I said earlier I wanted to
have no Preps stuff so that's no prep
all right and so we need 30 G more which
is going to be 1 and 1/2 cups this is 2
cups this whole thing so it's basically
going to be most of this all
right there's
one all right left
about all right a quarter in there all
right now you could probably just do
this and be pretty happy about it but I
like throw a little salsa on
there and just like that take your Chips
you take your take your sour cream take
one of these guys go on
top get really get in there there we go
there we go
yeah honestly a fox is
great it's really delicious it's
actually good and um this is
food and so this is how we'll make it
for camera real life I would take a bowl
I'd start with the chili I put the sour
cream on top and have the salsa I would
take the chips and I would dip it in
that way the chips stay crunchy doesn't
look nearly as cool but that's what I
would actually do all right and so that
is the bastic voyage of nachos and
protein it is 12 ways that you can have
zero prep zero intelligence 100% protein
as little fat little carbs as seemly
possible while having maximum
deliciousness in little time and if you
make a mosy meal tag me on Instagram or
Twitter I'm going to be rearing the best
ones and if you guys find something
that's even more delicious than the 12
that I had that is zero prep that's 100
grams of protein that takes almost no
time tag me in that cuz I might try
it myself but I'll definitely be sharing
it so thank you guys keeping awesome
hope you guys have an amazing 2024 get
as shredded as you want and uh that one
of these meals actually gets into your
rotation and becomes a main day and for
x-rated food content like this check out
my only fans m